I remember walking in that rehearsal
room for the first time never having
rehearsed a musical ever in my life and
there's lack sitting a piano and you and
Anika 90 roads are in the room just
warming up and I was like I'm but I
don't know what Lin Manuel Miranda my
name is Thomas Cal I'm Debbie Diggs
Christopher Jackson I'm Renee Lee skulls
Barry I'm Leslie Odom jr. I'm Jasmine
Cephas Jones my name is oak from at
Murray Rebecca what are some of your
favorite backstage moments from Hamilton
my man is a lot my favorite backstage
moments are always sort of moments of
connection that the audience doesn't see
the wig moment was my faith the wig
moment is hands down one of the best
moments of my life Anthony had to wear a
wig because he had cut his hair and he
had this wonderfully hilarious wig it
was Renee's wig I wasn't trying to do
him dirty like that answer yes it was
burning it was Benes with from
off-broadway and just fluffed it up
anyway like y'all put that on your head
until you did no one knew I didn't see
it until I got on stage and then I was
like what's happening he just laughed
hysterically I had so much fun our stage
manager came out of the shadows and I'm
talking like she's like get it together
one of my favorite moments is with you
Leslie
at one time we would start up yachting
we would you would with me I would just
have these like improv scouting sessions
Oh get me through it got those were
beautiful and rough months at the Public
Theater yeah we wasn't making no money
you know things start to grow one of my
favorite moments backstage always was in
the room where it happens there was a
moment where dahveed and I were both off
stage stage left and we would freestyle
together just until the moment where he
had to emerge as Jefferson and we would
always just fit in at least
two or four bars and it was our little
moment of connection at a moment when
our characters are as adversarial as
they could be I kind of walked around
mad all the time because George
Washington was kind of mad because Chris
was in angry mode all the time here's
Chris and Anthony Ramos just going at it
just like backstage like going at it
just like screaming matches if I never
hear Anthony Ramos I know he's thinking
it Chris would you just stop talking I'm
over here talking to Davi I don't I
didn't ask you for your opinion max you
for your opinion I didn't ask you act
Ali underscored love underscore 39 what
was the most surprising thing when you
read Hamilton script for the first time
ask Leslie I see first thing I did was I
saw the very first weeding of the
Hamilton mixtape in Poughkeepsie New
York I saw the first reading in a
99-seat black box theater I saw the most
the boldest freshest most literate
exciting piece of theater I'd ever been
given the gift of seeing that early I'll
tell you the song that I left that left
the biggest impression on me was not a
song you might expect it was the story
of tonight as a fan of the theater as
just as a casual fan of the theater of
the genre of this form I had never in my
life you see seen for men of color on a
stage singing together about friendship
and Brotherhood in my life and so to me
that was the revolution the image of
that pact such power that I committed in
that moment to like being the first
Hamill fan that there was I was I was
gonna bring everybody in my life to see
this thing because it was worthy
this is a question from Sam Middleton
via Twitter and he is at I'm
spamming at women well if you had
finished writing hashtag Hamilton after
reviewing events that have unfolded in
the u.s. in 2020 so far would you have
written it any differently
any guess and how it may differ that's a
fantastic question one of the sort of
great surprises of Hamilton is that it
doesn't change we haven't changed the
text of this show since 2015 and yet it
feels like it changes because the world
around it changes so fast things that
popped out when Obama was president may
not be the things that get a reaction
when Trump is president immigrants we
get the job done certainly gets a
different reaction if there's anything
political about the show Hamilton its
thesis is everything good or bad that
was present at the founding at the roots
of this the birth of this country are
still present the fights we had then are
the fights we are having now
conversations were having about systemic
racism and abuse and police brutality
and about revolution those are all still
present I'm gratified and humbled when I
see lyrics from the show at black lives
matter protests but because we are
dealing with the origins of this country
and how its based on ideals that we fell
short of the moment we wrote them down
I'm well aware every single one of these
characters even though they sing songs
you love are complicit in the original
sin of slavery whose legacies are still
being felt to this day the lyrics about
that in the show I think hit differently
in this conversation and they may have
in 2017 2016 or 2015 I think one of the
biggest themes of the show is you don't
get to control how you're remembered you
don't get to control how you're
remembered or who survives you and the
show doesn't escape that fate either and
so different things within it will rise
or fall based on where we are at reel
t-bone gaming asks I have a question
about Hamilton when you're laughing at
singing
sambal did you sing with a French accent
yes yes to the degree that I did
anything actually with a French accent
but my best approximation yes if you
know the real reason is is because
anything I can do to act through singing
is is gonna be helpful for me because I
am so uncomfortable singing at least
lack of more gave me a note one time
that was to stop worrying about the
singing and just act with the right
pitch as soon as he said that I did
everything from there on out with the
French accent this is a question via
Twitter from Kristin Queen saw at
Hamilton music when Chicago and can't
help but wonder what happened to Peggy
Schuyler surely at lin-manuel are you on
Twitter she's planning a sequel Hamilton
- Peggy's revenge hashtag you know you
wondered the same thing hashtag what
happened to Peggy hashtag - mrs. Lynn
you're all over this thing I am NOT
planning a sequel to Hamilton I don't
know on earth how I could follow that up
it's good that you wonder what happened
to Peggy she doesn't continue in our
story into the second act because sadly
Peggy didn't live that long the broad
outline of Peggy story is she married a
very rich young man and died pretty
young and as you can tell with Hamilton
we have so little time to tell a lot of
story and so if you don't survive the
act you're not getting to go to the
second act we're keenly aware that we
only have a limited amount of time with
you in our theater and so things that
happen are things like you don't find
out where Peggy ended up but it's just a
Google click away and Taryn stick wrath
yeah sometimes I think about the og cast
members of Hamilton like how did they
even get involved talk about a cultural
reset how did we get involved from all
different angles I think it's a long and
winding path to how we find ourselves in
these positions I think Lynn and Tommy
came to see me in
Natacha Pierre which was my first gig
out of drama school and I did a reading
of act 2 that the Tommy asked me to be a
part of and I met Bob Ethan I met Leslie
then I auditioned as well and I do a
live audition a lot and I don't get most
of the jobs I auditioned for
to this day you get what you're supposed
to have so I hope people realize that
and remember you know you keep showing
up and know that if you're you know if
you stay prayerful that which is yours
will be called - you kind of get an amen
amen
I was one of the last people to get cast
I didn't do the workshop I did theatre
before I was very involved with the
theatre world but not the musical
theatre world so it was a very like new
new process - to enter and I was kind of
one of the the new kids at school so I
was like extremely nervous our first day
of rehearsal my involved with Hamilton
came through my involvement with
freestyle Love Supreme
freestyle Love Supreme is a hip hop
improv comedy theatrical experience we
are kind of like a jazz band using jazz
and hip-hop and R&B and just whatever
form comes to mind man I am only in
freestyle of supreme because due to a
clerical error
I was substitute teaching the same class
with Anthony van in cially our friend
Anthony who was one of the founders of
freestyle Love Supreme
so we met teaching kids substitute
teaching kids which is just making sure
kids don't die
wow you're yeah which is a scary
prospect that you and Anthony were
substituting yeah yeah
and we were doing a show in New Orleans
when I found out about the existence of
Hamilton we were doing a freestyle show
and Tommy was like hey Lin is writing
this rap musical about Alexander
Hamilton I was like that's a terrible
idea and he said you want to do it and I
said are you gonna pay me and he said
yeah
I said yeah yeah as far as culture
resets is concerned time will tell us at
advo dude how many other Hamilton's have
you seen perform and do they
intentionally cast them to sound like
you saw it in Denver and if I closed my
eyes I would have thought it was you on
stage Tommy do you want to speak to your
ethos when it comes to casting
subsequent Hamiltons and other cast
members we cast Hamilton looking for
essential qualities not as any sort of
replication process Lin played Hamilton
in the way the he played Hamilton just
like Michael the whoa yay played
Hamilton the way that he did or Miguel
Cervantes or Jenelle Westman Joseph
Morales and on and on and on so the idea
is to try to make sure that each cast
member in every role is able to bring
all that they are and find out where
that intersects with the character but
that's the only thing that guides us
this question is from Atman Darla what
was the most difficult part of the
rehearsal process for Hamilton all of it
learning helpless and satisfied right
about sit down on a turntable on a
moving floor there's a big part of the
show where the floor moves and it's in a
circle we learned helpless and then they
said oh can you do what you just did in
that last song but backwards in this
next one and we would like excuse me it
like my brain hurt when I tell you that
my brain hurt for weeks it messed this
up on twofold cuz the first time we did
it we didn't have a turntable
remember that and then we got to the
theater and then got the turntable right
so we figured it out without the
spinning thing and then we get to the
spinning thing and it's like why are you
doing this to us after that first day on
the turntable I literally felt like I
had been on a treadmill for like 24
hours and every time I took a step I
just felt like I was moving I used to be
so emotional through the number of
satisfied it was always really hard for
me to sing the end trying to figure out
how I could kind of ride the waves of
the emotion and I think just in general
like I
kind of so flabbergasted I was just kind
of so dumbfounded by so many of the
moments that were happening it was
always hard to come in afterwards and
both him especially we had to sing after
somebody died I really want to do that
number again now like I want us all to
go together right now no prep no
rehearsal no refreshing you can be by
yourself on that one brother for you
okay I'll be like this for my popcorn
it's a most frightened I've ever been in
a theater for me I I was sort of like
the last principal to join so when we
started rehearsals I felt like I didn't
have a clue as to what was happening
when we were off-broadway I had I had
little blocking sheets posted at every
entrance and exits and like three
downstairs so every time I'd come off
stage I would frantically look at a list
like every time I moved through the
theater through the pass through
underneath to make sure that I was going
to the right side of the theater if I
had you know it constantly asked folks
like Davi Davi am I in the right spot
because I really don't know definitely
the know he was really hot desperation
makes you do a lot of crazy things our
next question is from Sarah Licht Blau
hashtag at exactly the same name good
for you for using your own name
Hamilton question that I need the answer
to all caps for need
what does Eliza's gasp at the end of the
musical mean please answer
I wish I could give you a simple answer
but that's that would be like telling
you where God Oh has been the whole time
they're waiting for God oh I think it's
different for each Eliza I've had
different conversations
it's heart-stopping isn't it and I do
think that it traverses time in some way
whether that that thing she's seeing is
Hamilton whether that things she's
seeing is heaven whether that things
she's seeing is the world now I think
those are all valid and all fair I do
think she is seen across a span of time
in that moment tell me what do you think
you staged it again that conversation
which is distinct with each Eliza as I'm
answering the question because I'm not
going to because I feel like that is
actually between Eliza and Eliza it just
was something that that came out of a
very natural organic process in
rehearsal and in performance and Linn
was one of our greatest advocates for
that for that moment existing and it's a
testament to Lynne and the generosity of
spirit that that's not written in the
script the show ends with the final
lyric that that he has written and the
final notes and yet he had the
understanding that there maybe was
another moment that could extend beyond
that it's something that a lot of folks
talk about and I'm happy that there's a
there's a dot dot dot at the end of our
show as opposed to some sort of
definitive State hashtag not an answer
from a cat Chester I think is how that's
pronounced or higher or anyway you know
you know who you are how does the
Hamilton cash perform that show every
night without crying because I cried
like five times just watching today I'm
just curious please let me know we do
grind up I cried almost every night I
cried during quiet uptown pretty much
every night I remember the first time I
heard quiet uptown I was like a mess and
then it--like we kept being a mess and
then after a while I don't mean to ruin
anything but then it's it's work you
know we just we go to work we do the
show we enjoy it play moves you you got
no there's no time for pauses or really
the thing moves so you have to move with
it you have to keep up with it when you
do a show as a theater actor over a long
period of time it's beautiful to see how
that show changes two things you hear
the things that move you things that
motivate you please God let there be a
tear Naomi president
[Music]
or lives up at BFA ythe
Oh after seeing the show my biggest
question is how does that Hamilton cast
have time to snap that / suite / make
videos during the show hashtag all caps
all caps all caps I don't mean to spoil
the Broadway experience but if you ever
ever wonder what people are doing
backstage they are texting their friends
back they are making business calls
between scenes I'm gonna get for dinner
if the show is about to end and they
know that the order is going to take
about thirty six to forty five minutes
to get to their home and they will be
home in 30 they know that this
particular song I'm gonna make my dinner
order on stage some people I know some
people oak who had no problem having
their phones on stage oh you won't even
know it but they're going through the
grocery lists while they're like
straight up all that stuff it's like
before I started the show I think Philip
su put me on Instagram and when grabbed
my phone one day and put me on Twitter
fortunately with Hamilton you know the
leader Lynne he really I I just used to
joke he texts the world that's what he
does with Twitter he texts the world
he's in a constant conversation with the
world and so he really he really you
know he's a very interesting genius and
that he he's extroverted in that way
he feeds off of that energy and so we
were really encouraged in a unique way
just and we needed to because we were
desperately trying to find a way to give
people access to the show so the way
that we made it not exclusive because we
hated the exclusivity of it was to use
social media to share as much of the
show as we possibly could with as many
people as possible at ball speak folk
sense to say noted this from Hamilton
belong on a sexy playlist
what's the debate I mean yes deny that
like base that comes in and no the way
that Lin wrote it it's like a slow down
kind of like R&B jam I loved singing
that song because it was such a jam it
was such a jam so yeah why not back
Chris Geiger okay serious Hanson
question can deer Theodosia be just an
incredibly loving sweet song or do we
have to think about their fates I never
think about their face in that moment
I'm always thinking about their
motivation and now when I watch the
movie I'm thinking about the fact that
these two young men at each had a
daughter and another son there's no
better answer than that I will say that
watching the movie gave me probably you
know one of the most special memories to
me of that time that I hadn't thought
about a long time because I'd never seen
it I remember the 52nd Street project
that was one of the early workshops that
we did of the show when we were just
putting the whole thing up for the first
time there was no lights or anything
like that it could be so India Theodosia
now the way it's staged the light goes
down on Burr and the light comes up on
Hamilton when it's his section you know
and at 22nd Street I had to figure out
what am I going to do
literally cuz I'm here on stage and so
what am I gonna do while Lynn sings
we're not in the same space and I bowed
my head one day and I was like oh he can
pray Bernie and pray Burke and pray for
his daughter and I didn't have any kids
yet but I I was able to find the
connection with it cuz I said I believe
my daughter can hear me somewhere what
she's not here yet she's not yet but I'm
singing to her still and so I said by
the end of that show I had said over 500
prayers for my for my little girl before
she ever got here and you see that on
this in this movie I had never seen it
before you I bow my head and I say a
prayer for my little girl
thank you for joining us for tech
support thank you for you
incredible questions thank you guys so
much for always supporting us since day
one keeping us honest keeping us
inspired always showing your love for
the show and being a part of this family
thank you for introducing me to Twitter
didn't know I could tweet thank you guys
for sending your questions I can't wait
for you to see this movie I just got a
chance to see it Hamilton July 3rd it's
on Disney Plus it's it's streaming in
your living room however you want to
watch it hopefully you'll feel even more
inside of this family than you already
do I'm really excited to hear from
people on places such as Twitter their
experience watching the film make art
let's use this to few lists make sure
that they're registered to vote and
their friends are registered to vote and
that they if they are of age to
participate in the upcoming elections
because it's very important not only for
the world at large but also for yourself
in in our current climate today after
we've all watched George Floyd murdered
free 8 minutes of 46 seconds I think
it's very very important for people who
are seeing that especially young all
that they love the younger people who
are watching it the importance of
utilizing your voice in the way that
Pippa said registering the vote
Hamilton's platform was he kept he
wasn't just yelling it in the streets he
then went home and like drafted he
drafted how he thought the country
should change he not only pointed out
what was wrong with it but he went home
he said this is what I think is wrong
with it this is how I think we can
change it and then he went out and
shouted for everyone here and I think
that is a message that every human being
regardless of your race needs to do
right now that's what's up same love
y'all thanks for being us with us on
this journey black lives matter